foreign
live from the headquarters of Ramsay
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio it's the
Ramsay show where we help people build
wealth do work that they love and create
amazing relationships I'm George
Campbell Join This Hour by my good
friend Dr John deloney best-selling
author and host of the Dr John baloney
show and we're taking your calls America
at triple eight eight two five five two
two five I know you've got a lot going
on in your mind and you're dm'ing me a
thousand questions and I say call the
show because it's a lot easier to talk
to you in person than to go back and
forth staring at my screen I get the
same thing call the show call the show
call the show hey and I I got to tell
you so Dave and the entree leadership
team has their annual
2500 to 3 000 Business Leaders they take
over a city basically and they're here
in Nashville and last night they took
over the entire Opry the Grand Ole the
grand old operation epic it was a blast
there was all these different country
singers and actors showed up a comedians
it was a hoot but I'm walking through
the lobby with my daughter
and this guy comes up and goes oh hey I
just saw George Campbell too
he goes hey you're John deloney I just
saw George Campbell and I and I just
instantly said George King was the worst
he hit me he punches my arm and he goes
I love how y'all just rib each other and
I said I don't think you understand like
I don't like anyway and my daughter the
whole thing was awkward oh but man he
was he was protecting him some GK man
people are very protective I think it's
because I'm small they feel like they
have to defend me yeah you know they
can't tell that over the phone that's
true well we really are great friends
people often wonder does John actually
like me the answer is no but we are
really good friends so that helps so I
mean I like you you keep growing on me
oh not not literally but I have not
grown on me since the fifth grade
Johnson well hey if you want to have
some fun today uh you know while while
the cat's away the mice will play is
that what they say
okay we're gonna go to the lines now and
it's just John down there goes George
making it weird Kendra kicks us off in
Charlotte North Carolina Kendra please
save the Ramsey show how are you doing
good thank you
um a little back story my husband and I
have we've been through Financial Peace
University and we've paid off our debt
several times in our marriage and been
debt free and then we just seem to creep
back into debt so we're on baby step two
again and
um we're both on board and and we're
working to pay off our debt and we're
following the plan but I just have a lot
of anxiety around it and
um it's not that I don't want to be
gazelle intense but I'm just finding it
difficult this time because I have such
a fear of going back into debt again who
have you lost trust in you or your
husband
um
both of us in different ways at
different times
I mean I
probably don't have a lot of trust in
myself I I feel like when we've done
this before we it's almost like the
whole time we're in baby step two we're
planning for what we're going to
purchase when we're out of debt if that
makes any sense you know we kind of have
a running list and then you know months
years later that list becomes the things
that put us back into debt so so what
kind of debt are you getting back into
each time
uh credit card debt okay so have you
ever cut up the credit card and close
the accounts or are you just paying off
the credit card debt and then hanging on
to the card
card and close the accounts before yes
and then you get out of debt and you go
we're going to reopen a credit card to
make purchases
yes
and then what are you spending that
money on is there something in
particular each time
no it's it's nothing that we need is it
online shopping is it Amazon is it
Target give me something tactical here
trips things for the house and you guys
don't have the money in the bank and so
you go well we'll just put it on the
card
correct and what was the reason for
getting out of debt the first few times
well we don't want to be in debt I mean
but you do
but not but not really kind of
sort of yeah maybe yes but you want the
stuff more than you want to be out of
debt
and it's okay to say that out loud but I
think what we're experiencing here is
there's a spending addiction
yeah can I take a shot in the dark
yeah just say you you're an idiot no
you're wrong did one of you or both of
you did one of you have a rough go of it
as a kid
yes
um which one
I did
give me 30 seconds of context about that
I had a mom that had
um a sickness where she ran up a lot of
debt and a lot of it was in my name
using my social security number when I
was
a minor was Dad around
yes so that meant the spending was the
thing we all pointed at but that meant
you had a house that was chaotic
Barry and you watched your parents not
be very stable together Fair
yeah it's very easy and here's why it's
it's a common response that when you
grow up in that sort of chaos or abusive
environment
the whole world becomes about a
for lack of better words a fantasy into
the future
this is going to be this thing and
you're always living for then and it
becomes virtually impossible to live
right now
because living right now is a skill and
living right now for you got was
terrifying it was scary it got you hurt
and so everything became about living
then living then living then even though
in the present it's brutal
is that you see what I'm saying
yeah I've never thought about it like
that but yeah so what you have to do is
this whole thing is an identity shift
you guys can do the thing y'all can do
the hard thing
but you get to it and then you start to
you you live in the future we're going
to be out of debt one day then you get
there and you don't know what to do
so you default to your fantasy list and
you just start the whole cycle back over
again
and then you give yourself a new
deadline so instead of giving yourself a
new deadline a new uh Finish Line If you
will not deadline a new Finish Line to
achieve
give yourself dreams to move forward to
and this is going to have to be
something that y'all practice and it's
going to start with an identity we are a
couple that never borrows money that's
who we are
that's in our DNA that's in our bones we
don't do that
that that's the only way George that's
the only way I know of
to not fall back we're just not people
that's just that's just not who we are
the same way as y'all would say we're
just not a couple that cheats on each
other we're not a couple that hits each
other we're not a couple that comes it's
a daily decision yeah and that habit
becomes a part of who you are so Kendra
here's what I'm gonna do I'm gonna give
you every dollar premium so that you
guys can get on a budget that's only
part of this puzzle you need
accountability because it takes two
people to make these decisions so you
need to say no we're not going to open
that up because remember don't forget to
remember how good it feels to pay off
debt and not to go back in and on top of
that freeze your credit with all the
credit bureaus so that there's a stop
Gap from you opening up a new line of
credit it's a big hurdle yeah so cut up
the cards today you're going to pay off
this debt how much is left
thirty thousand thirty thousand in
credit card debt on vacations and
spending
yes have a conversation with your
husband tonight and Say Never Again is
this going to happen we're gonna get on
a plan we're going to keep each other
accountable we're gonna freeze our
accounts we're going to get a monthly
budget and we're going to become those
people who just say if we don't have the
money for it we don't get it that's
called delay gratification and it's a
huge part of Building Wealth and
accomplishing your dreams together this
is the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
hey folks you know that sinking feeling
when you make an offer on a house you
love and then you hear there's another
offer you need the Churchill Mortgage
home buyer Edge super fast pre-approval
and a secured interest rate plus a five
thousand dollar seller guarantee gives
your offer the best chance of being
accepted the home buyer Edge from
Churchill gives you an advantage over
those other guys go to
churchillmortgage.com today to learn
more
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
Ramsay personality George Campbell
joined by Dr John baloney and we're
taking your calls at triple eight eight
two five five two two five well uh good
news and bad news our 10 sale ends today
but the good news is you still have a
chance to get your hands on some of our
life-changing books and tools so if
you're looking to get out from under
that pile of credit card bills that eats
up those paychecks every month grab Dave
Ramsey's best-selling book The Total
Money Makeover Millions have used his
practical plan in the book to take
control of their money and change them
and their family's future it's only 10
bucks and you can also get his latest
book baby steps millionaires for 10
bucks as well where he shows you how to
build a legacy how to invest the right
way once you've paid off your debt and
there's a ton of real life stories to
inspire you folks who actually did this
stuff and became baby steps Millionaires
and if you want to improve your
relationships and mental health pick up
my friend Dr John deloney's questions
for humans conversation cards and has
been own your past change your future on
on the 10 sale for the first time ever
ever yeah that's big so if you've been
holding out for a sale on that book this
is your chance it ends today shop these
deals before they're gone go to
ramsaysolutions.com
sale that's ramsaysolutions.com hey I
want to say something about this so it's
a ten dollar sale
I've had multiple conversations in the
past few weeks with some some sort of
meta-narrative that sounds like this and
I know you've had it because it's about
money and people are reaching out to me
about money then I know it's on people's
hearts and Minds
hey man uh
um you know they're gonna barely pass
this debt ceiling thing and then the
Supreme Court is going to strike down
the student loan thing and they're all
gonna have to start repaying and we're
gonna have this massive recession in
October September August all right
that's just like the and there's some
variation of that story going on and on
first I want to say I've heard some
variation of some story every three
months since I started working here
there's always uh the crash is coming
John you eventually throw enough darts
backwards you're gonna hit Bullseye and
everyone's gonna be like oh that guy's a
genius see I said that's right
but let's say that is let's say you knew
a Calamity was coming in three to five
months
why would you not
do everything you can get every piece of
information data come up with a plan
right now to shore up things as much as
possible in five to six months if you
are staring at
three years you haven't paid student
loans and it's about to come
and you're looking at your budget you
realize whoa I bought a car that I
couldn't afford over the over the two or
three year uh student loan holiday I did
this I'm in a house I can't afford start
right now start right now if George if
you call me you're like hey there's a
tornado coming your way and we live 10
miles from each other I'm not gonna wait
until it's sitting on top of my house
I'm gonna move my family down to the
basement and we're gonna get right
batting down the hatches we're kind of
prepped for that moment but we'll be
ready to rock and roll right so all I
have to say is this
if you're if you're sideways if you know
somebody who's sideways for God's sakes
ten bucks
10 bucks for a Total Money Makeover can
is a road map to okay I don't know any
other thing that works I clearly am not
doing this right ten dollars and I can
go in a new Whole New Direction it just
doesn't make any sense to me when you
got this kind of Dave starts giving all
of our crap away for half price yeah not
that I'm you're not setting not that I'm
on 100 commission he cuts the
commissions in half but like man if you
for 10 bucks you can hand it to your son
or your daughter or your friend and say
hey
Winter's coming
just here's a coat here's a jacket just
for that moment I just don't understand
the turtle up and let's just all be
scared and pissed off let's just start
let's just start fun to Doom scroll and
hope that you stumble upon the right
advice the right tool and the right
advice is usually some fraudulent idiot
saying something that's going to make
them wealthy at your expense when when
times get bad don't do that well the
good news is our books uh don't involve
any shortcuts it's all the long cuts in
our books it's do the hard thing the
first time the right way so that you
don't screw it up and then call us and
say hey I did I did a dumb thing I saw
Dave posted on his Instagram the other
day it was a video of him
I mean 30 years ago oh yeah 1995. that's
when the video came out George interview
he told a same joke that he told the
other day when I was on the air with him
and I don't say that to make fun of him
I say that to say he's been saying the
same thing for 30 years and it works it
just works man it works every time you
work it so don't miss this whether it's
for you or for someone in your life
ramsaysolutions.com sale it ends today
all right let's go to Joseph in Columbus
Ohio Joseph welcome to the show
all right thank you guys so much George
Sean hope you guys are both doing well
thank you so much for having me we are
what's going on with you
so uh I guess the con uh the question I
have is a bit convoluted but it's one
that I know myself and a couple of my
friends my age who've been asking and
kind of debating over the last couple
months
um but I guess it's really a question of
for me
um when is Saving and trying to be
financially stable detrimental to my
life goals and plans of moving forward
and that that being a sense of moving
out and kind of moving on with my life
and the reason I say that is
um two years ago I graduated from
college I started working as a
non-acquisition specialist and moved out
um to Cincinnati Ohio uh with a partner
I had at the time the relationship fell
through when I moved back home and I've
been there since and I've been trying to
save my money and be as smart as
possible
um with being financially conservative
but
um I guess my question is really when
does saving as a priority in my life
become too much if that makes sense and
kind of hold me back from
moving on that being like moving out and
I guess I've kind of hit a wall where I
don't really know if I'll ever feel
truly financially secure and moving out
and I'm just not really sure what I
should do moving forward when it comes
to being smart with my finances versus
actually how old are you
24. okay and you're saying if this is
for all those folks who are in their 20s
even 30s saying I live with Mom and Dad
I'm doing it because it's a financially
right move for me but at what point does
it go from being a safety pad launch pad
into a crutch and a hammock right
absolutely
I think a good filter is using this time
at home to be a comma and not a coma and
a lot of people get comfortable and
their expenses are low and the inflation
and it just becomes the plan and it does
stunt their growth
as far as their careers their social
life their marriage everything and so I
think having an exit strategy is key
here
I I
I'm a huge fan of man move home for a
few months six months get your feet
underneath you save up for a particular
goal well that's a down payment I'm a
huge fan of that what I think is a
dreadful idea for both kids and parents
is not moving in with a deadline
in six months you're out of here even if
you get to six months and you'll have to
sit down and be like hey we're three
months away from plan X but in six
months you're gonna have this much money
in the bank and then you're on your own
again my question for you is have you
healed from that breakup
uh yes it that I guess that's a bit of a
tough question to answer but I would say
largely yes I think I'm in a better spot
with my career path and personally and
both personally and professionally I
guess I would say that I'm definitely in
a better spot I where's that guy that
two years ago took a job across the
country and moved moved out there to go
go have an adventure
looks to me like that guy got his heart
ripped out of his chest and then he
walked back home and he went back to his
parents house and that guy hasn't
recovered yet
I think you're definitely right on that
I I definitely was a different person
before and after and I I think that
prior to it um I definitely I don't want
to say I was necessarily
prone to taking risks but I think now
I've definitely become more at risk
adverse absolutely so you used a great
word there here's the suckiest part
about relationships whether you're
married 70 years or you just met
somebody a hundred percent of
relationships this is from the greatest
apparel a hundred percent of
relationships is a risk
somebody's been married 70 years my
grandparents were married 73 years my
granddad leaned over and told my
grandmother
um I'm gonna go get something to eat do
you want something and she could just be
rude and mean or she could say sure
right it's always a risk
what you've done is you were bench
pressing and the weight was too heavy so
you put it back on the bar and you've
you took all the weight off the bar and
now you're just pumping the bar and
you're going nowhere you gotta risk
putting weight back on the bar I would
say sit down get a dollar amount 10
grand 50 Grand whatever the number is
and put a deadline on it and make
yourself move out of your parents house
get an apartment get an apartment it's
not going to stunt your goals it's going
to make you stronger and then you're
gonna find your professional career
accelerating at an unprecedented Pace
man you got to get back out there I wish
there was another way there just isn't
[Music]
we've been doing business at Ramsey for
more than 30 years by now we're a
well-oiled machine but it wasn't always
that way yes we've always had a vision
always had determination and a drive to
help people but what we didn't have was
one central place to access all our
numbers so that we could get further
ahead or quickly see when we needed to
Pivot we were always jumping back and
forth between different systems and
spreadsheets so when netsuite by Oracle
helped us Wrangle our Revenue inventory
expenses and more into one place it was
a game changer and netsuite's number one
Cloud Financial system can help your
business gain the same visibility
because businesses thrive on timely data
and next week's real-time analytics can
help your business have immediate access
to your numbers daily so you always know
where you stand and you can move quickly
so go to netsuite.com Ramsey today and
set up a free product tour that's
netsuite.com Ramsey
[Music]
foreign
I'm George Campbell joined by Dr John
deloney you're listening to the Ramsay
show and this is a show about you about
what's on your mind what's on your heart
what keeps you up at night the fights
that you're having at home the longings
you have the vision for your life that
maybe didn't pan out we want to help you
take the right Next Step and the number
to call is triple eight eight two five
five two two five Tanya's up next in
Bend Oregon Tanya welcome to the show
I am about
thousand dollars in medical and credit
card debt and I have a home that I have
about 350 000 worth of equity in and I'm
wondering what your advice would be if I
should sell my home
which would require moving out of the
area because in Central Oregon you can't
re-buy for that and pay off my debt or
if I should do the baby steps and and
stick this out for
five years and try to work out of this
are you a single family household single
income no no no my husband is home he
did get hurt this winter and so he's
been off of work for a couple of months
he's just getting back to work did he
have any workers comp or disability pay
or anything no no we're small business
owners so basically it it's all on you
we haven't
yeah we had no health insurance at the
time and we had no
workers comp or any kind of insurance to
help us through so our savings is gone
and if I if I talk about it too much I
might start to cry you've earned those
tears you've been through hell that's
scary it's real real scary sorry to hear
it's scary now and
we're to the point
where
surgery in May and May 2nd and he's just
been released to go back to work so
today is his first job really working
um back at what he does which were a
small painting contractors and and I
have a small bookkeeping business so
he's back at work full time now good and
so this is the question is
um but I don't know if we have the if
we're going to be able to fish out of
this month by month do I go start
delivering pizzas and he go start you
know working double jobs
um you guys have a child left at home
one child
one child left at home yeah and she's in
high school okay so let me let me know
this story so
I'm going to walk you through my
thoughts on this and George I want you
to copy on if I'm wrong okay is that
cool can we tag team this
great thank you okay so
my wife and I had incalculable six
figures of debt
but it what I was it was surrounded by
what I would call a a single event now
that single event took several years and
it was both of us going to graduate
school and then more graduate school
but it was around an event it wasn't our
lifestyle to be insane with how we spent
but we looked up we did something dumb
life happened to us whatever you want to
call like we looked up and we had this
debt
and I had this house and so we sold our
house
to expedite it kind of like you said
five to ten years
because that wasn't who we were and this
was a moment and here was the big kicker
we were planning on moving out of that
Community anyway in the next couple of
years
and so it expedited all of our goals it
wasn't just a get out of jail free card
and now we're renting it was hey we're
probably gonna move in the next couple
years anyhow and this gets us out of
this and this cleans up this one giant
mess that we made and we aren't people
who run up a bunch of debt anyway
so if you were to tell me this has been
our home for 30 years this is our
community this is where we're known
um but we're willing to do whatever it
takes to get out of this thing I'd
probably lean on you and tell you to
figure out a way to stick it out because
that's your root if you tell me hey we
got one more knucklehead in the house
and then we were thinking of downsizing
and moving to the coast or moving Inland
then I would say I would tell you to
strongly consider it you might have an
opportunity to clean up a one-time thing
that was some a medical issues that
popped up we're not people who borrow
money that's just not who we are this
just happened life happened at us and
hit us in the mouth and we have this
opportunity to walk away so I throw that
at you tell me what you're thinking
about that what was your plan what's
your roots with this community you live
in tell me tell me more
so it is a mixture of
um the past couple of years of me
struggling uh medically I've had I've
put a ton of stuff on medical and then
on credit cards to be able to go you
know um we didn't have health insurance
and I needed
um
to have some medical stuff done and so
we just did that on credit cards and it
was really irresponsible and then
there's two vacations on there that we
shouldn't have done that we just figured
you know we'll be able to work and pay
it right back off and
um so what's your household income today
Tanya with your husband working now
today with his with him in back to work
um
probably 60 Grand a year between the two
of you
well his
yeah yeah between the two of us
um him being able to get back to work
right now
um how much money do you guys have in
the bank
dollars um we're looking at probably two
grand total are you an accountant
I'm just a bookkeeper I'm not a licensed
accountant I I just I do bookkeeping and
payroll for a couple of small businesses
what has kept you from going to work and
do books for a small business directly
or work with a medium-sized business and
make fifty thousand dollars a year with
life insurance I mean I'm sorry medical
stuff with health insurance
my medical stuff just over the past
couple of years I um
I struggled with some pretty serious
medical stuff that have been just trying
to get back on my feet I took some
pretty serious diagnoses last year and
are these mental health issues
yeah okay
what about husband is he able to
again I I'm just looking at a work
environment where McDonald's is paying
twenty dollars an hour
you know what I mean and so if you can
make 60 Grand or 55 grand I don't know
what the math is left off my head but if
you can make that kind of money with
health insurance
I know we want to work for ourselves and
I know we're great at painting but it
might be time to say hey I gotta make a
left turn because my reality has shifted
is that do we just kind of give up on
this dream of self-employment and
and go back to work
um I don't think it's in either or maybe
hey we're gonna go work at a company for
now get out of this debt until we have
the freedom and ability to choose
give me the letters that were your
diagnostic do you mind doing that
um PTSD okay
um BPD
and which is borderline personality
disorders that's the one that kind of
really kicked me it's very challenging
yeah
um
I'm in PTSD anxiety and depression which
I think the anxiety and depression sure
fall under the BPD diagnosis sure so you
know a Cornerstone of of borderline
personality disorder a Cornerstone is
how intense you feel things 10x what I
feel
right right and your body burns with
anger where items kind of mad right or
I love somebody and you are overwhelmed
with love right
yeah also a Cornerstone of borderline
personality disorder is very staunch
either or you love me or you hate me
and it could just be I'm kind of annoyed
today
see what I'm saying I want you to keep
what George said and put that write that
on the Note
and put it somewhere on a mirror where
you can see it every day and here's what
I want you to write because what George
said is very very wise
it's almost never either or
almost never backed into a corner it's
almost never oh so we just give up on
all of our dreams no
but you maybe take two or three years
and dig yourself out of a hole
so we don't ever get to own a house
again no but you're sitting on three
hundred thousand dollars of equity maybe
we clean this sucker up and we go get a
fresh start if that's what we're gonna
do anyway do you see what I'm saying
right and that's really what I'm what my
so Tanya I would not go sell the house
tomorrow because truthfully the house is
a shortcut that doesn't actually change
what's going on and it's a temporary
stop Gap so what I would do is say can
we get our income up to 100 Grand and
start throwing 30 35k at this dead every
year and it's gone in three years and we
save the house boom and the last worst
case scenario is we sell the house to
get out of this but we still have to
deal with the underlying issues so hang
on the line we're going to gift you one
year of Financial Peace University I
want you and your husband to go through
that because right now you need a whole
lot of Hope and that's what's exactly
what it's going to give you
[Music]
foreign
welcome back to the Ramsey Show
hey if you're a new listener to this
show and you want to dive deeper into
the principles that we teach the lingo
that we share on the show The Ramsay
baby steps you can go to
ramseysolutions.com and click on the get
started button and our team has created
an awesome tool to help you figure out
the next best step for your financial
Journey based on where you're at today
that's ramseysolutions.com click on get
started Carter joins us up next in
Charlotte North Carolina Carter welcome
to the show what's going on
thanks for taking the time this
afternoon guys absolutely
I I find myself in kind of a situation
where I have you know always heard
people talk about investing and kind of
where to start but the last couple
months at work I've had a um a pretty
decent increase and I find myself now
where I really wish that I would have
considered sooner not sure where to
start how to start but um my my family
has recently grown and now I find myself
wanting to create a more stable future
for wife and child and so just looking
for some advice on kind of beginning
steps and and where to go from there
what a stable me a loaded question I'm
sorry what does the word stable mean to
you when you said I want a stable
financial future
money in the future and and once my
child is older be able to kind of teach
them the wise
Financial mindset but also not having to
worry about you know where things are
coming from or when the next meal is
just just want to create this
you know living in a not a luxurious
lifestyle but comfortable so we don't
have to worry about things okay and this
kind of increase in Pay has got you
thinking about how to do that and how
soon you could do that right how old are
you yeah I'm 27.
okay and what do you make
um so my base is around 90
000 per year
but the last couple of months I have a
base plus commission structure and the
last couple of months my commission has
been about 15 grand each month wow it
Ebbs and flows but with this additional
income I don't want it to just kind of
sit around we did buy a house about a
year and a half ago we've paid the
medical expenses on the child and so now
it's kind of like let me look towards
the future and what I need to start
doing okay do you have any debt other
than the mortgage
um I've got a car loan but if more so
just to increase my credit history and
my length of credit what do you need
credit card oh you did it now man Carter
Carter we were having such a good time
we had you now like this was going well
what do you need the credit score for
now you have the house just so my wife
is not going to be working anymore and
we have a house but we want to move
within the next four to five years okay
so your mortgage is going to keep your
score going school system
yeah yeah I mean to be frank I could pay
off the vehicle right now it's just one
of those things that maybe my money I
throw some into investing there it is
Carter cat's out of the bag all right
hold on before George does this every
month I'm putting about a thousand
dollars extra towards the car loan just
to get it done
Carter what do you do for a living
I work in recruiting okay
um in the financial services industry
there you go okay
I have a family member who works there
and does quite well so excellent
um before you go before George gives you
the tactics because you're a tactics guy
is that fair
correct one thing I don't think you've
done yet and what I'm about to say dude
my 22 year old self would have would hit
me in the ear for saying what I'm about
to say I need you to hear to hear me
what I'm about to say sounds woo-woo and
sounds like I'm holding crystals and
pouring essential oils all over my head
while I'm telling you this okay
okay George is going to give you a plan
a set of tactics
and if you don't do what I tell you it's
not going to be worth the paper you
write it down on all right okay
you have to just gives me to even say
what I'm about to say you have to feel
how your life has changed
because you have not done that
you're a dad now man
you have always seen those guys as the
ones who get bonuses and that's you now
man
those guys are the ones who have a house
and an awesome wife and a family that's
you now
and it sounds like you're trying to keep
at arm's length all of these transitions
that are so beautiful and so credible
and so life-changing you're trying to
keep them at arm's length by getting the
right plan in place plans are important
but way more important is holding that
little baby and saying dude of all the
Deads in the world I'm so grateful that
I get to be yours
do you see what I'm saying
yeah absolutely and if you sit down and
spend the next two or three months
absorbing all this life change how much
has this happened it changes how you
dream and it changes how you sleep and
it changes how you interact with your
kids and then George is going to walk
you through game on and I'm gonna be
honest you're doing some stupid stuff
with your money George will help you
with that all right but it allows you to
say okay
I'm doing this for a reason I'm not
running from something I'm not do I want
them set up perfect now man I'm doing
this because I love that kid I'm doing
this because I'm a good dad I'm doing
this because I'm a great husband see
what I'm see how different that is
yeah you gotta feel it you gotta feel it
everything everything in your life is
different now and that's what makes it
great all right George sorry I feel like
I had to tell myself that was a good
good caveat John so Carter here's my
thing you called in asking how you can
set your family up you want a
comfortable life nothing crazy
but yet we're aiming towards risk in
order to get that Comfort which doesn't
make a whole lot of sense so we're
saying hey we're going to keep the car
loan we're gonna keep this dead hanging
around we're gonna invest our money and
that's somehow going to create a
semblance of safety and so I'm not angry
at investing but I think there's an
order and a method to the madness so if
I'm in your shoes how much money do you
have total cash in the bank
um around 35 000. what's left on the car
um maybe ten thousand eleven thousand
okay that leaves you with 25 Grand let's
call that your emergency fund three to
six months of expenses
yeah great now we can begin investing 15
into retirement accounts which I'm sure
is not cool amongst the Youth of America
today they're going I'll get away to him
60 to 10 yes and you can still retire
early and so with any money left over
after the 15 I'm paying off that house
because let me remind you what you
wanted you wanted your family to never
have to struggle never have to worry and
guess what having no payments in the
world helps you do not worry
and so I know that's the least flashy
information and I honestly I doubt
you'll do it because you're probably
going well my mortgage interest rate is
like three percent I can invest that and
get six percent right right you're doing
the math in your head and the whole time
you're holding this brand new
nine-month-old who feels that angst on
you all day every day versus the dad who
has not even a house payment and it's
like can you believe inflation and he
goes I don't know what is it because he
literally doesn't care and you're
talking to two dummies here
do you know what our combined uh IQ is
seven our combined FICO score I I
honestly I couldn't tell you my credit
score I I I can't think of a number I
care less about I don't even know what
it is I don't care
and I'm not rich I just don't care about
my FICO school I don't care about that
number it does nothing for me
it's the greatest Flex to not care about
the credit score way more than the 850.
not caring is even better so Carter
here's what I tell you to do pay off the
car stop worrying about the credit score
and start Building Wealth the right way
which is the slow way be the tortoise
and not the hair be the crockpot in the
world full of microwaves and man it will
change everything as far as how you feel
internally and how your family feels
because you can out earn your stupidity
you get you make an incredible income
you can go to a whole bunch of stuff and
still put food on the table so this
really isn't about safety because you
guys are going to be okay
what this is about is justifying I want
to keep my family safe with truly an
underlying sense of some pride some fear
a little bit of greed going man I can
make some really good money right now in
the market you're going to be you're
going to retire multi-millionaire agreed
yeah yeah so what's the rush be a
multi-millionaire with a smile on your
face not with constant rocket diarrhea
because you can't you you can't feel
your guts right hey stay on the line
we're going to give you Financial Peace
University for a whole year you and your
wife can go through this it's our gift
it's your it's your shower gift and
y'all go through this thing together and
it'll walk you through every single
lesson you know it you'll get there that
puts this hour of the Ramsey Show in the
books our thanks to the incredible crew
in the booth we've got Emily we've got
Ben we've got Austin we've got Andrew
holding it down and my co-host Dr John
deloney and you America will be back
before you know it
[Music]
hey George camel here if you love the
show and you want a deeper dive on your
money Journey we've got a Weekly
Newsletter that gives you helpful
articles and tips on following the
Ramsay way just go to
ramsaysolutions.com today to sign up for
the newsletter again that's
ramsesolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
foreign
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio it's the
Ramsay show where we help people build
wealth do work that they love and create
amazing relationships I'm Ramsay
personality George Campbell joined by my
good friend Dr John deloney and we are
taking your call to Triple eight eight
two five five two two five and we're
going to try to tell you the truth on
the show even if it hurts and often you
know truth tellers in a world gone mad
sound sound a little mad don't they John
yeah we sound like the crazy one
sometimes just
telling the truth makes you look nuts
but we're here for it and we we believe
it to such a deep level because we know
that it works we've heard countless
stories seen people on the debt-free
stage and when you you know too much you
know ignorance is bliss until now
until you see what's behind the curtain
how the sausage is made and it makes you
go I don't think I want one of those
credits course no thank you
so we're happy to help you today whether
it's with money relationships mental
health debt investing we are here for
you America we're going to kick it off
with Josh in Tampa this hour Josh what's
going on
hi George hi Dr John thank you guys so
much for taking my call sure
um yeah so my wife and I are on baby
step 3B and we've never had any debt as
a married couple and she's brought up a
couple times now that we should get a
credit card to build our credit for when
we're ready to buy a house and I was
just wondering how uh how can I softly
and lovingly explain to her that the
risk isn't worth the very little reward
that comes with having a credit card how
long have you been married dude
we have been married for about a year
and a half yeah I was thinking you've
been married less than two years so you
still think softly and gently works
I'm just playing it's all good all right
so
um George I'll let you do the honors
well I'm I'm curious Josh
obviously you are in the boat of we
don't need the credit score right right
and she's in the boat of like why would
we not it's going to make our life
easier does she know about manual
underwriting if you explained that it's
not that difficult to get the house
without a credit score if you do it the
right way
yes I have explained that to her she's
she's come at it I guess she's come at
it from The Stance of
yeah that's true but if we did have a
really good credit score we could get an
even better interest rate and
I I don't I just ended up telling her
that I would feel really uncomfortable
getting a credit card and so it hasn't
it hasn't come up to a boiling point of
a full-on fight I just want to
like stop it before it gets to that
point well the other piece of this is
there's a lot of misinformation out
there when it comes to getting a house
without a credit score that you're going
to get a horrible interest rate and as
someone who's actually done it they
don't care about my opinion of course
they just go but the truth is that you
can get a great rate without a credit
score
if you get a 15-year fixed rate mortgage
with 20 down I will get the same score
as the guy next to me who has a great
excellent credit score
but if you told her that what would her
response be
is she wanting to do a 30-year is she
wanting to put less down where's the
hold up here when it comes to buying the
house
well
we live in a really high rent air area
and you know she wants to wait and we
both really want to wait to get to have
kids until we are in a house and so
there's kind of I think a lot of
emotions tied up into getting a house as
quick as possible so I think that's
playing a bit of a role in
her looking at other ways to get in one
quickly so my guess is she wants to put
as little down possible into a 30-year
mortgage
uh not as little down but yeah we
definitely had had conversations of
doing the 30-year mortgage
have you guys been through Financial
Peace University
uh no we haven't I've grown up of you
know my parents grew up on Dave Ramsey
and so I've you know I followed his test
and I was a big fan but to her this is
all new information you're coming at her
sideways and it's creating some tension
very true yeah because you're used to
this stuff this is like mind-blowing
jarring information to her
so she I think she also needs some time
with it under she needs to understand it
at a deeper level and you guys need to
be more aligned on those that vision and
those goals here's here's where I would
start if I were you and I was kind of
giving you a hard time about only being
married 18 months I think this is
actually the perfect time for y'all
I would love to see y'all go on what I I
wish I had another word for it man
because this is so corporate language
but I would love to see you all go on
some sort of strategic planning retreat
and here's what you're just here's what
you're discovering and here's what
you're etching into stone
here's who we are gonna be
this is the kind of family we're gonna
be and I want you to etch your values I
want you to Anchor them into the Bedrock
of of your soul and I want you to hold
your beliefs really really lightly
what I mean by that is value we are a
people we're a family that never borrows
money
I also believe I wanna I I should have a
house before I have kids I'm gonna never
touch that value that value is etched
into into stone we just don't borrow
money this is who we are I don't build a
build up a credit score whatever the
heck that is get some Airline point
we're just we just don't borrow money
this is Who We Are
we don't cheat on each other we don't
punch each other in the face we don't
murder we just these are just things we
don't do
and we have this belief we have to have
a house where we have kids I'm gonna
hold that one real Loosely and I'm gonna
go talk to some people who have had a
bunch of kids before
one of the greatest experiences of my
life was the two years or the one year
we lived in an apartment when my son was
two it was a blast
we got to know my neighbors he got to
see it was amazing and never in a
million years would have done that right
so that's a belief that I held really
Loosely that I got some new wisdom on
but when it comes to values you guys
haven't had the who are we going to be
yet y'all are still arguing on the plays
you want to run you're not arguing what
kind of team we're gonna be and that's
where I want to see you spin your energy
on the front end
and that take tends to take a lot of the
nuts and bolts questions off the table
because it's just who we are
right
and I think every new married couple
could benefit from that I I mean shoot
you've been married 25 years you need to
have that another one of those strategic
plans who are we now where are we what
do we believe what do we want to be
about about in this season but man I
think that's where I'd start is hey
honey what kind of Life Do You Want to
Build Together
who do we want to be
and then when you decide I want to be a
house that never does this cool we're in
now you're going to sit with somebody
who's way smarter than me like George
and he's going to walk you through okay
well here's how you buy a house then
here's how you do this then here you buy
a car then
here's how you become a millionaire
uh-huh Josh a lot of people ask me hey
man you you got a house you paid it off
early you did it without a credit score
what do you attribute to that and 100
it's being on the same page with my wife
we pre-decided all of these things we
pre-decided we were gonna save up a huge
down payment pre-decided we're gonna do
a 15-year pre-decided that we're going
to go through the process of manual
underwriting and that changes the game
it made us move so much faster than us
bickering over the tactics so you and
your wife go listen to the episode of
the fine print that I did it's called
the dirty truth behind your credit score
have a listen to that I'm also going to
gift you guys Financial Peace University
because I think she just doesn't have
all the information and you've had it
for years and so to you it's a
no-brainer to her this is still she's
figuring out why do we have to live
outside of the Matrix The Matrix is a
great place to live it's comfortable in
there the pill we can get out and so I
think with time and like John said that
intentional planning you guys will get
there so I hang on the line Emily's
going to pick up we're going to give to
you one year Financial Peace University
we're wishing you the best with the
house buying process
thank you
[Music]
foreign
y'all there's a lot you can't control
when it comes to health care but there
is something you should check out that
can help Christian Healthcare Ministries
chm is not Insurance it is
budget-friendly biblically based Health
cost sharing that means a community of
members helping share the burden of each
other's health care costs they help
people just like you in all 50 states so
see if chm could be right for your
family learn more today at
chministries.org budget
[Music]
thank you
George camel here joined by Dr John
deloney this is the Ramsay show
if you've changed your life with the
money principles that we teach the
chances are is because someone you know
lit a fire under you Mom Dad gave you
the Total Money Makeover as a gift your
pastor offered Financial Peace
University at the church well now it's
your chance to share that same hope that
you discovered with someone that you
love and the best way to do that is by
giving them the live and give box this
is the perfect gift for The Newlywed
couple a graduate in your life it's
everything they need to win with money
and it comes with Financial Peace
University The Total Money Makeover book
and the baby steps millionaires book and
right now you can get all of that for
just 89 bucks but this deal ends today
so give the people you care about a gift
that actually matters and that is hope
that's Freedom grab a live and give box
today at ramseysolutions.com
box that's ramseysolutions.com slash box
Taylor joins us up next in Oklahoma City
Taylor welcome to the show
are you with us yes hi hey how can we
help
hi um so I have what I think is an
income and a debt issue I'm a single mom
of a 10 month old baby boy and
um I am barely I'm not making a name I'm
not even gonna lie I'm not making
against me hey thank you for telling us
I know you don't want to say that that's
where all yeah that's I'm so proud of
you I know that was hard to do just then
I heard it good for you it's incredible
hard um I love my job so much and my
boss is incredible I actually was just
able to be very honest with her and got
a seven thousand dollars dollar raise
wow um and that is keeping me at not
making ends meet
um oh I'm laughing with you because it's
sad if we don't laugh we cry
thank you
um so just any guidance on what what do
I do
well you've got the 10 month old what
are the logistics around caring for the
10 month old
um very difficult I have four days a
week daycare he comes to the office with
me or today we're working from home one
day a week
um I have very very little outside of
daycare child care that is a free option
to me
um and I'm about 30 a week for groceries
so I can't pay a babysitter oh Han no no
is that is dad in the picture at all
um no dad has a substance use disorder
so I also don't anticipate child support
okay how much do you make a year
000. how much debt do you have
um I have about 30 000 in that and what
kind of debt is it
thirteen fourteen thousand um on my car
I'm upside down in my car
um I have about
2500 still on my credit card that is a
closed account and cut up and we're
working on paying it down
um and then I also have about 14 000
that I Consolidated from that credit
card with my credit union so that it was
at least a lower interest rate and a
fixed payment
um every month okay what's the car worth
you said you're underwater is it worth
12.
um I could sell it for eight
yeah were y'all married
no
um how long are y'all together
three years
how much of your heart got taken with
with this whole mess
a whole lot of it there's a protective
order involved okay
because here's what I hear so we just
want to get better I know but here's
what I hear yeah I hear a you have to
see when you told me and George that you
just went and had one conversation with
your boss and she whipped out 7 000
extra dollars for you you know what that
means that means you're an absolute
gangster and there's one person on the
planet that doesn't know that and that's
you
because here's what happens when you
marry somebody when you fall in love
with somebody when you try to build a
life with somebody who's struggling with
addiction disorders
you start to lose your own center of
gravity and then you lose trust in you
right
it's actually the field I work in now
there you go there's substance use
disorders yeah but listen
my counselor will attest I don't care
what field you work in it's easy to care
for other people it's real hard to look
in the mirror right
yeah yeah there's there's some some
luxury in doing that though right
because it's uh it's about taking care
of my cat now that's that's where I'm
not taking care of me is taking care of
the greatest gift you can give that kid
is to begin to believe in his mom again
[Laughter]
you're so great
it's both and
okay and what I mean by that is you got
to be real clear you love this job and
it may not be able to pay your bills
you really really want to take on all
this debt and clean all this crap up
yourself because I'm a single mom and I
can do it and you may not be able to and
what I mean like you may have to just
turn the keys to the car in
like there's there's there's a there's a
basis and you know this with your work
with people who struggle with addiction
the Baseline is you have to own reality
here's where we are right and that's
really hard to do and you're looking at
a little baby and you're trying to you
you want to keep this picture of this
world that we want up so much and yet
here's reality
I mean I slept on the floor in the past
year I don't mind getting rid of stop
that's not right
you've got to stop living in survival
here's what I'm gonna do I'm gonna give
you some free financial coaching we're
gonna pay for it we've got Financial
coaches on staff and you're gonna stay
on the line and we're they're going to
walk you through your budget and walk
you through here's what I would make
Cuts I'm so sorry you're all right
you're all right dude we got George has
a kid on the way I've got a kid that's a
sound that's good that's makes joy in my
heart that's great yeah um
mom's gonna have to go see a counselor
okay you're gonna have to go talk to
somebody
mom's gonna have to
um reach out and get a group of
girlfriends in her community or some
people at a local church that will help
with some child care so I'm doing some
trades
mom's gonna have to have some hard hard
conversations about
um
work and I love serving people's
addictions but I can't live right now 54
000 in this community in my deck all
that stuff George
um it's sitting down and owning reality
it's really scary
really really scary and Taylor you are
very capable so I have no fear that you
are going you're not going to get out of
this debt it's going to happen it may
take longer than you want it may take
some extra side hustles it may take
asking for help even when it hurts your
pride and it may take getting connected
with a local church I mean our church
has a has a Ministry just for single
moms to get them cars so imagine if you
could go hey I'm going to sell the car
I'm underwater on it I'm going to take a
loan for the difference from a credit
union and I'm going to find a beater car
to get around in from A to B I'm going
to see if I can work at home an extra
day a week to avoid a little more Dake
you're going to have to do a thousand
little things that add up to a whole lot
to go all right I got a thousand bucks
extra I can throw at this at this debt
that's 12K I'm Gonna Knock this thing
out in two and a half years I'm gonna go
earn 75 000 and it's not going to be the
job with this cooler boss or his caring
of a boss but I'm gonna go get I'm gonna
go get that job because that's what I
got to do for the next two years to
climb out of this hole that I'm in right
yeah but this is a solvable problem but
right now it feels so overwhelming I
can't imagine what you're going through
doing all of this as a single mom a 10
month old and while also doubting
yourself
and dealing with your past struggles and
your past hurts all right so we threw a
lot at you and a lot of it sounds
Kumbaya pushback yeah I asked for
tactics guys push back
um I I know all of it I
I don't know how to do all of that in
the dishes you know
um I I heard getting a community I'm
really grateful to have thankfully here
in Oklahoma City I grew up here I have
my people
um I have I'm amazing friends do you ask
for help
oh occasionally you do not that's the
problem I'm learning too okay you have
to
this isn't something you have time to
learn to do you have to if you are my
friend Taylor and uh you had a group of
friends and I knew what you were going
through I bet guys we're all going to
get together everyone venmo a bunch of
money we're gonna just bless the socks
off Taylor we're gonna get her a new car
and beyond that can I tell you this if
you were my friend what an honor it
would be for you to call and say hey can
you and Sheila come help
and what a gift that would be to me
forget you it would help it's a gift to
me let your friends love you let your
community love you
you've got to ask for help so when we
say get community get go through FPU all
this stuff hang on the line we're gonna
give you everything we got but you have
to say here's what I need will you help
me you're not a burden Taylor ask for
help and they'll be happy to give it
hang on the line we're gonna give you
Financial coaching with one of our staff
we're going to give you Financial Peace
University and I'm going to send you a
copy of Dr John's own your past change
your future
[Music]
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees
everything's backed by their why
action guarantee and
free see whyblinds.com is the number one
online retailer of custom window
coverings go to blinds.com now and save
45 off selected products visit
blinds.com today for more info
foreign
[Music]
this is the Ramsey Show I'm George
Campbell joined by Dr John deloney the
number to call is triple eight eight two
five five two two five you jump in we'll
talk about your life your money your
relationships whatever is on your mind
our question of the day is brought to
you by neighborly your hub for home
services for over 40 years neighborly
has an exclusive network of trained
local service pros backed by the
neighborly Done Right promise so it's
not done right neighborly we'll make it
right visit neighborly.com today to
learn more
all right today's question comes from
Ron in Louisiana or
potentially John sitting right next to
Georgetown when I saw this question I
was like John did you actually sneak
this question for yourself
read it John Ron from Louisiana writes I
heard about you from my son and I saw
your video about the supposed crash of
the dollar in government crypto you said
it's all Bs but that goes against
everything I'm seeing on YouTube okay
that's funny I don't care who you are
that's a brand new sentence
that sentence has never before been
spoken in the English language
Ron
I'm not even gonna finish a question yet
I just need to address you
things on the YouTube
aren't always real except for this show
so if you're watching our show on
YouTube yeah it's more
whoa
damn by the way it's not everything
you're seeing on YouTube because we're
on YouTube and we don't say that the
algorithm is showing you very specific
things because you keep clicking on them
and then it just keeps showing you more
I will click on that video yes if you
were to click on strength of U.S economy
it would just send you a bunch of videos
that talked about that so all I have to
say is this on to the next I own my home
and vehicles I have no debt and I have
sixty thousand dollars saved good for
you brother that's awesome that's really
impressive
and I was thinking of buying hunting
land my thought is that if the economy
collapses or we lose electricity I can
just live off the hunting land
what would or wouldn't you do in my
financial position
hmm okay so this is
there's two parts here I mean
financially he's in a great spot he owns
his home Vehicles no debt 60 000 saved
now wants to buy some hunting land
that's a cool goal the motive behind it
can be worrisome but also still not wild
now the apparently the paranoia and
conspiracy of it all is the wild part
but wanting to buy land and of you know
living off the off the grid that's a
dream for a lot of people and John you
can attest to that yeah so I like
hunting land I like hunting I like being
able to take care of my my wife and I
our Gardens are massive I like all we
love that
I also have zero illusion that if the if
the US dollar implodes if it goes away
if it goes away
we're probably not going to make it we
just got to make peace with that and I
know that we all can watch Survivor
shows and it's so great
um it's gonna be a rough go
uh it's gonna be a rough go so I think
the idea man yeah if you can afford if
you can buy cash uh pay cash for hunting
land get it that's great man I'm always
looking to buy more land I love it
um I'm saving right now for another
another thing so I'm all about that if
you're doing it as a hedge against the
world collapsing I probably wouldn't do
it for that reason if you've got other
goals if you've got colleges you got to
save for if you don't have any
retirement or anything like that I would
not do it in lieu of that
that's fair I think uh I I've talked
about this on the show that when I and
again Ron I I'm smiling because I'm you
I was this guy for a while like it's all
coming down I have it mapped out like a
beautiful mind it's all going to fall
down and here's what's gonna happen and
I remember sitting with the CEO of our
CFO of 150 million dollar company I walk
him through my plan because I'm gonna do
I'm this is gonna happen it's gonna
happen
I'm gonna cash out all this do this buy
this land and he looked at me and he
said hey man like I don't really
understand what your plan is here
because it was insane
and he goes please like you're my friend
don't do this
his name is Kelly he was one of the
greatest men he said please don't do
this and I walked out of that meeting
and I thought to myself he didn't get it
he doesn't get it he's a part of the
system right I was I wasn't well but let
me tell you this so my buddy Todd who's
a finance wizard he works in finance
he's the one who gave me this line and
it was really revolutionary for me he
said I kept pepper in him about what if
the dollar does this and what if happens
here and what I'm eating my beanie
babies because all I've got left and
he said hey John I don't have and this
is the quote I don't have a meteorite
plan
I was like what do you mean you have a
meteorite plan and he said hey I'm gonna
make the best choices with the
information I got in front of me and the
information I got in front of me is
economies go up and they go down and
over the Long Haul they continue to inch
their way up and up and up and if that
changes
you think your life is going to be just
not that happening and you're still
driving to work you won't have a work to
drive to people will be shooting you for
your water they will eat your pet like
you can't imagine I have all this gold
John I've stockpiled gold I've got time
such as this great we will burn you down
with your golden right I mean there's
800 000 people walking down the highway
we don't have a a scale for that outside
of crazy movies and so his his wisdom
was so great
things will be so radically different
that to plan for that is madness it's a
waste of it's a waste of your current
day so be smart be intelligent um don't
be dumb if you're into hunting land and
you want to great man I'm all about it
if you're buying it as a hedge to when
it all goes down I I'm just telling you
you're gonna have 25 000 people crashing
onto your land oh I got my you you don't
you don't you don't well my thing is the
world may end now it's a little
egotistical to think it's going to end
in my lifetime a little prideful to
assume that but if it does end until
then I want to have a good quality of
life right and you don't have that when
you're stuck in paranoia of what could
be that's you it's it's your goal the
goal here is peace I want peace in my
heart that's a good word one piece of my
home and I got huge Gardens I got a deep
freezer
family
but also like I don't know my wife
drives Prius and so I mean it's like
it's it's it's it's kind of both hands
it's kind of both in so Ron hey if I'm
you brother you are doing really really
good I would turn YouTube completely off
and just not turn it back on and I would
sit down with your wife your kids and
make some long-term plans about how you
want to invest your money and if buying
Huntley is part of that awesome just
pays cash for it now John in your book
redefining anxiety you share a story of
kind of you spiraling out of control yes
in the intro of the book how does
someone recover who's kind of in this
mindset because this is a hard it's easy
to say Hey Ron don't worry about it bro
but how do you actually there's
literally only one that I that I've been
able to find
um you have to have somebody that you
trust whether it's a therapist that you
pay or a medical doctor or a close
friend
um I was blessed my wife called one of
them I've called Todd call my buddy and
said and his wife who is a close friend
it said John's not all right and they
drove three hours and they had a new kid
we had a new kid and the whole trip was
quote unquote into the guys of our kids
were meeting together for the first time
and but it was really like an
intervention the guys was
my wife knew I trusted that guy
and we walked down the driveway and he
said hey this has to stop you're not all
right this has to stop and I remember
being pissed when he left
but that was the first thought like
oh maybe it's me right but I don't know
a way that somebody just comes out of
that hurricane spiral on their own it
has to be through relationship which
makes it so difficult especially when
people other people are part of the
Spiral right that's what made covet so
hard is other people were the scary
thing where the zombies and that was
also the thing that was going to make
you whole was to sit with other people
again right yeah that isolation is
dangerous and just having the echo
chamber of the other people who also
think it's all going to go down also
dangerous dude you have to have people
with common sense every friend needs one
it's all coming down that guy's
important in the in the food in the
group John is the one on our friend
group always that guy
but I have to have people in my life
they're like okay that's cool man
um but go ahead and take the match in
your 401 right well and you're you're
doing the right things here in in this
situation where you don't have any debt
you don't know anyone anything I mean
even 2008 terrible financial crisis
many people survived it it went
financially the it wasn't fun
and collapse completely horrific numbers
uh was it 35 unemployment that meant 65
almost 7 out of 10 people were still
working right so we lose perspective
with all of the ah that three out of ten
was massive don't ever want to do that
again and there's always perspective
there's always perspective and that's
what that's what friends and Community
bring to us yeah our financial piece is
a part of that equation but you don't
want a flat tire you also have to have
the relationships have your physical
like I can't do that hey I'm thinking
about investing in this but I'm thinking
about investing in this I have a guy I
got a buddy that I trust that I can call
and you give me good answers get you a
guy this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
this is the Ramsey Show I'm George
Campbell joined by Dr John deloney if
you're a fan of this show be sure to
check out my friend Dr John deloney show
it's on YouTube and podcast and he does
it right next door to the studio and
it's a real good one and if you want
more for me which is a rare small group
of people you can check out smart money
Happy Hour podcast I have with Rachel
Cruz that's real fun and then a brand
new YouTube channel where I'm making
hopefully fun entertaining personal
finance videos breaking down all the
traps and Trends to help you guys so
you're blown by me numbers wise well do
it man I think it's because I went all
in I'm a YouTuber like a true YouTuber
yeah you're like a YouTube Native and
it's highly produced a lot of pop
culture and memes you know less sad
calls that are people in really tough
situations so I have that going for me
and they're short that's crushing dude
you're long-winded I'm short-winded
that's
you told me not to talk about your
height on the air anymore so I won't but
leave it alone John but all right let's
go to the phones Caleb is up next in
Chattanooga Tennessee Caleb welcome to
the show
hey guys thanks for taking my call
what's going on
well I'm having some
Financial struggles with my girlfriend
really like I'm I'm doing all right
myself we have separate bank account
um you know I've never really thought of
combining them or anything but she just
hasn't been handling her finances very
well
and it's kind of putting like a real
strain on our relationship
in what way
what's your involvement with her her
money
she hasn't been able to help out with
any of like the bills we live together
ah there it is okay so a lot of combined
bills she can't pay the bills
no like she she can hardly even pay her
own bills
one
is she working full time
yes and no
um
that that was the issue like she took a
job that didn't really pan out and so
for about a month or two there she
really didn't have the income coming
coming in
okay and
you know on top of that she didn't
really have any money saved up to fall
back on so she was putting stuff on
credit cards
so you're are you covering all the bills
right now
yeah like so my brother was like the
household belt Caleb is the problem
Financial or is the problem you're
growing increasingly
disgusted is probably a strong word but
you're growing increasingly frustrated
by the character of the person you're
trying to play house with
yeah I mean like I don't want to like
you're are you starting to believe like
I don't know if I want to be married to
someone who rolls like this
yeah I mean that's definitely I think
you kind of hit the nail on the head
right there okay because here's the deal
one George and I are both going to tell
you if if you're not married and we can
say there's a moral issue fine but
there's there's a legal issue if you're
not married
paying each other's Bill playing House
playing each other's bills it just makes
for a mess dude if you own a house
together the whole thing's just so
complex
and so we would tell you man If You're
Gonna Play House get married and because
at least there is some legal protection
as you separate things out if things go
sideways if you're just dating it just
turns into world war three and four and
five but beyond that man both George and
I are married we both are all in on on
the woman that we are with and if
there's a season where we gotta do extra
that's what I mean there's no problem
there that doesn't seem to be your issue
that seems to be like you're just
getting increasingly frustrated that
this is who I'm dating this is a
like come on and she's just like man you
got it is that right
yeah I mean it that's definitely
you're going down the right right hole
there I mean what what kind of
frustrates me is I feel like a pressure
like she wants the our relationship to
move to like the next level what is the
next level
you guys are already living
that would be like marriage or kids ah
and I'm not comfortable doing that with
her because of her finances have you
told her that no hey hold on it's not
because of her finances
it's because of her character
they are expressing themselves in her
finances
don't get those two screwed up because
she's going to make you a bunch of
promises and say okay well I'll pay my
credit card off and I'll go get another
job that's not going to cure the
underlying which is I'll do whatever I
want I don't have to participate in
building make creating a home together
and also in her defense
Ike y'all are kind of just making up
there I mean you're just it's very
wishy-washy and it's hard to it's hard
to Anchor into wishy-washy right
yeah yeah I agree
have you had a conversation with her yet
about all this yeah I I have and it just
ends in like arguments and yelling and
stuff I'm I'm just kind of at my width
end because
as even as we speak like she's getting
like opening up new credit cards account
card accounts and stuff like that have
you have you said to her have you said
to her
being in debt scares me to death
and when you borrow money I can't
breathe
and moving forward in my home the home
that I want to raise kids in and build a
family with
we are going to be people who don't
borrow money and so if that's the way
you want to get through your world I
love that you are opting out of
relationship with me
have you said that
no I haven't have a backbone man you got
to stand up and speak your virtues out
into the world
because you're gonna wake up three years
from now you're gonna have two kids
you're gonna be considering a wedding
and you are not even gonna know what day
it is you're gonna be so frustrated
is that fair
yeah I would never listen to me don't go
tell me hey I called these guys on the
radio they told me to dump your butt
that's not what we're saying at all I'm
telling you the only thing in the world
you can control is your thoughts and
your actions so you go be a person of
character and say exactly what you need
and what you feel
and then she gets to opt into that and
y'all create a life together or she gets
to opt out of that and have a bunch of
shiny plastic toys
that's it
I know I made that sound real simple I
know it's super way more complex than
that but Caleb this is this is eating
you alive man this is turning into
resentment this is turning into you
feeling like you're enabling her poor
decisions and if I'm in your shoes I
just go this relationship isn't working
our values are too dissimilar for this
to work and I wish you the best and you
know what that means someone's got to
move out and it's gonna get real awkward
real quick
because your first thought's gonna be
like I've been paying the bills and
she's gonna say bye Felicia and the
whole then the whole thing starts over
the whole thing then George and I high
five and we're like told you so but but
we won't do that I know the next few
steps are gonna be real hard but what's
even harder is just sticking this out
hoping things change and it just gets
worse and then you've got a lot of
resentment and uh John deloney uh he he
quotes another super smart psychologist
guy who said choose guilt over
resentment yeah and you're gonna feel
guilty You're Gonna Go ah she's already
going to a tough time I can't believe I
could do this to her but man it's gonna
choose that over hating
the woman that you you love right or
hating your mother-in-law or hating your
dad like choose guilt choose the
boundaries right
um and it goes back to
um
I don't think I'm a lot of talked about
it yet but I think I've talked about a
little bit
um it's a secret well it's just like I
got a new book coming out and in the
fall and but one of the discussions
um comes from the great Michael Easter
which like you gotta
it's hard it's life is hard if you are
overweight by 100 pounds it's hard
and it's so hard to lose 100 pounds so
you're not toggling between oh one's
real easy and one's real hard my life is
super simple if I'm 100 pounds
overweight and my knees hurt my back
hurts and I'm exhausted and like it's
it's that's not you're not choosing
between a real fun time and a hard time
losing weight they're both hard
right now what he's choosing is nobody
taught that dude how to say his needs
out loud and nobody taught him how to
build a sit down with somebody and build
a picture of what marriage could look
like for us and building a life and a
home together no one's done that doing
that will be almost impossible and
living with somebody that you don't
share their values and they are just
digging a hole that expect you to clean
up that's hard too so it's not an easy
eat one's easy and one's hard they're
both hard you got to just choose your
hard right one One's Gonna Leave lead to
Freedom what's the path that's right
that's a good word One path heads Heads
to Freedom wishing you the best choose
your heart man that puts this hour of
the Ramsay show in the books my thanks
to all the folks in the booth keeping
the show running my co-host Dr John
baloney and you America will be back
with you before you know it
[Music]
hey it's Dr John deloney if you love the
show and want a deeper dive on your
money Journey we have a Weekly
Newsletter that gives you trending and
helpful articles and tips on following
the Ramsay way just go to
ramseysolutions.com today to sign up for
our newsletter again that's
ramsesolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]
[Applause]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and stored Studio bit my tongue
there John I got so excited this is the
Ramsay show where we help people build
wealth do work they love and create
amazing relationships I'm George
Campbell joined by Dr John deloney today
and this is your show America so call us
up at triple eight eight two five five
two two five and if you like this show
please consider subscribing leaving us a
review wherever you're listening and
sharing this with a friend John we just
got some really cool data in from our
listener survey and it's amazing to see
how many new listeners came from Word of
Mouth people saying hey John you got to
check out the show you gotta check out
the show and there's only a certain
amount humans can handle in their life
in the repertoire podcasts and shows
they listen to like 400 a week I can
listen to a thing exactly two of those
hours they're saying hey Ramsay show
you're going to get an hour of my time
that means the world to us and uh we
truly believe that these principles
while it can be entertaining to listen
to the show it can also change your life
and we one of the things we talked about
in there was the word of mouth it used
to be I worked with the same 25 people
and I might tell one of them over lunch
or a couple people about hey man I did
something crazy I paid off all my debt
right and they like what like that used
to be Word of Mouth now you can just
listen to a podcast episode and if it's
meaningful you can just text it to 25
different people and so it's expanded
this idea of word of mouth or you can
just forward the link of a YouTube clip
or a YouTube episode to your mom or your
friend or whatever and so it's the
ability to send these episodes out so if
you if you listen to an episode if you
watch an episode and it it's meaningful
to you it's it's impactful and you think
man this would really my mom needs to
hear this call send it to her forward it
on to her man and bring everybody into
our weird gang it's a party we love it
grateful for you guys this is your show
let's get to it
Tanisha is with us in Washington DC to
kick off this hour Tanisha welcome how
you doing
hi
um I'm okay how are you we're doing well
how can we help today
um so to make it plain I am bored at my
job
me too me too no you're not you guys are
loving yourself
okay so you're bored you want to get out
of this thing
yes and um like I work from home and I
am like pulling my hair out but I have a
second job and um
I I got it because I started the the
baby steps so I'm paying that so I paid
my credit cards off and now I have
student loans but the career I want to
go into I have to get a master's so I'm
like do I take out more of that or do I
wait
what's the job I don't know what to do
um what was the question what's the job
you want to go do
so I want to either do School counseling
or be a social worker excellent
excellent and what do you do now
and Cardiology A cardiology Cardiology
research research assistant
um so here's what I do if I were you
well George tell her the sad news
the sad news is I would not take out any
more student loans and you'll move at
the speed of Cash ever ever I know which
means this may be a two-year Journey
instead of a now Journey or let me tell
you let me tell you what might happen
so let's do this let's say from this
point forward
Tanisha is a person who never borrows
money it's just not on the table this is
not who I am what that means is now
Tanisha is a person who figures crap out
I will figure this out
my first
bachelor's degree master's degree and
PhD all loans all loans
same with my wife Lots six figures Lots
then we said never again
and so in my next job
uh they had a benefit where I could get
one class and then I went and said hey I
got these professional development you
pay to send me to a conference every
year what if instead of going to that
conference that that dollar amount is
about the same as a class can I trade
you for that and my boss was like yeah
that's fantastic and I said it would be
more of a benefit that's great
and so I would love to see you go apply
at hospitals
that might pay for you to go get a
Social Work degree
nursing or might pay for you to go that
is going to support you in that Journey
not
make you go into more and more and more
debt I would love to see you get on the
phone and see if you can make that
happen I think you can find that per
that place
I'm afraid of that though I know because
I don't know if they're going to help
are you more afraid of being told no are
you more afraid of being completely
chained to debt it's a worst case
scenario though they say no we can't do
that you go all right all right well
cool Shake It Off have fun
so what's it going to cost to go to an
affordable program in your area or
online
Community College
school like Liberty it'll be like 37. so
33 000 total wait hold on 33 seconds at
a community college yes you were on your
mind it is not right I'm not kidding
well master's degree they don't have
Master Grade Community College
well the the one that I where I where I
am there is a master's degree for a
School counseling
mm-hmm yeah
if I were you I'd get on the phone with
local school districts who are so
desperate for mental health
professionals and teachers
and I always see if there's a
possibility that they would hire you and
help you get credentialed
were we at a school I never thought of
that a hundred percent yes
like schools are struggling all over the
country to keep people
and you might have to leave DC because
DC is really really expensive
yeah I feel my parents so I know I can't
even afford to be on my own well it may
be time to start looking across this
great country and figuring out another
place to go but again since you're a
person who never borrows money you're a
person who has to figure it out and
figuring it out means we have to do
stuff that we didn't plan on or want to
or think that would be great but that's
what we're going to do because we don't
borrow money that's just who we are we
choose Freedom over everything else
how much more debt do you have left
um
and what was the degree in that you got
sociology okay
and that's all of your debt
that's all of my dad just paid off my
credit card a couple of months ago
awesome and what are you making
uh combined with both jobs about 50
000. okay that's um after not paying
taxes and everything at least that's
what I made last year and living with
your parents your expenses are super low
yeah I pay like 300 on rent right now
that is a blessing let's take advantage
of that knock this debt out as fast as
we can and then cash flow the most
affordable program that we can do and
like John said there's so many ways and
it's going to be you're going to get
super creative and go oh my gosh I had
no clue that they would be willing to
pay for my education and see if you can
find it an online program I know hey
here's why because we love you and
here's the other reason I don't want you
to put thirty six thousand dollars of
debt on top of the 65 you already have
and then make we owe 100 to 110 000
making 60 Grand as a social worker you
know why because I know them those are
my friends and they can't breathe
and it takes the fun out of social work
and the dream that you've had there's
not a lot of fun in social work now it
becomes I got to pay the bills how am I
going to do you can't serve somebody
else you can't save somebody from you
can't pull them out of the ocean when
you're drowning
true right and so my friends who are
mental health professionals and it's
almost my entire Community who oh crazy
amounts of money they can't breathe
don't add yourself to that number
[Music]
love those future clients enough
to go in with non-anxiously I don't owe
any money now I can really jump all in
[Music]
I'm George Campbell joined by Dr John
deloney you're listening to the Ramsey
Show open phones at triple eight eight
two five five two two five Mariella
joins us up next in Lexington Kentucky
Mariella welcome to the show
hi thank you so much for having me
absolutely how can we help today
well there's a ton of things but the
main concern right now is my husband has
been lying to me and we've been working
through baby step number two but he's
been hiding like Financial
purchases that are really big or
how is he hiding them
um well this past week I found out that
the vehicle that we have been paying
hundreds of dollars from this month over
a thousand in repairs
um he had put a lien on it several
months ago so we couldn't even scrap it
this month
um which we're down to one car now
um and so that was one of the bigger
lies recently why do you put a lien on
his own car
um he's been
he told me did he borrow against it like
the equity out of his car
that's my understanding like he got
a certain amount of money and then this
is when we were starting to work
together on the baby steps he said that
um we paid off some things using that
money because I was asking him where did
it go like why would you do that but he
said we he didn't feel like we had any
money and
um
so he went to one of those payday
lenders who said we'll give you three
thousand dollars but I'm holding the
title of your car like a Title Max looks
like an old Pizza Hut one of those
places
I just learned all of this not very long
ago and so we we had also
um had like similar things happen in our
relationship like with Lowe's
um he spent thousands that I didn't know
about there at Lowe's
yes let's see Ryan
well I talked to them not too long ago
and because I received something in the
mail and that was how I found out in the
first place was the cards and was
originally primarily in my name because
we got this was white like years ago
when we first got married we got a
washer and dryer
then recently like he purchased a
lawnmower that was for him to use at his
grandparents house
um
and it was like six thousand dollars and
I didn't even know you bought it and
then but that's almost paid off that's
the promotional purchase
and there's about 9 000 in just random
less than 299 dollar items they told me
we need to come to Jesus meeting tonight
and we said everything gets put on the
table I would say George before that
walk her through how she can pull her
credit report and find out what's out
there yeah you can pull your credit
report for free
annually and it'll tell you every piece
of debt that is owed to your name
and he needs to do the same here's what
here's what I think Mariella can I just
be honest with you I don't want to be
alarmist but be honest with you
I think this is real bad is what I think
and either he is a bumbling goofball of
a ding dong
who just is walking through life
like a three-legged turtle
or
he has a very deceitful person who is
spending money on all kinds of things
and lying to his wife's face
and when that happens
it's very rare
that they're not hiding some sort of
addiction or some sort of other person
in the relationship
and I'm not telling you that to freak
you out I'm just telling you this is
what we do for a living
it is rare that somebody just keeps
blowing up money and spending six
thousand dollars
for a mower for your grandparent what
are you doing you know I mean that's
just Madness
and that tells me there's somebody who's
out of control
so if it's okay yeah I was just going to
tell you yeah the back story to that was
kind of his
um he lost his grandfather who was
essentially his father figure a couple
years back and
um
I think part of it is like
in his mind he feels responsible to take
care of things for her totally get that
totally get that so I think that's kind
of where that came from and I was
getting to where I could forgive that
and I was we were working together I
thought so now I'm at square one again
because I'm like you tell me you're
telling me the truth and then you're not
well but there's also a difference
between I need to take care of my
grandmother
and I have to spit on and completely
dishonor my wife
you don't have to do one to do the other
I can completely honor my grandmother
and get on Craigslist and buy me a mower
that barely runs that will get the work
done
she did have a push mower I believe it's
just I know I know here's the thing how
long you all been together
five years approximately
at some point and that doesn't have to
be today
at some point you're gonna have to stop
defending him because you've been
defending him for a long long time right
you have an answer for everything I'm
calling out and George and I are both
husbands we know how this game works
but you you're will you you keep
defending him and defense so you can
defend him all you want till the end of
time
but you can't breathe right now and
George and I can both hear it
he's broken your trust and that is the
foundation for any relationship and it's
going to take a long time to repair and
it's going to take even longer if he
continues to make these Financial
mistakes without talking to you and even
if he explains it you get a vote and
right now you haven't had a vote in this
relationship have you it's always been
him going well you don't understand I'm
doing the um I'll figure it out I got it
don't worry about it and you're going
along with it right
well before he had like complete control
over everything money-wise because I
didn't have a job because I had no that
is all kids no but now that's not yeah
hold on he doesn't get the money because
you don't have a job my wife stays at
home she works um but she stays at home
and we do this thing together
that's not a reason
well now it's not that way
um and he did come to a point where he
said okay you have a turn and you try it
like he wanted to let me see if I could
do a better job because we both knew it
wasn't working with him making the
financial decisions so
he's been in the driver's seat long
enough and he's been crashing the car in
fact he got rid of the car
everyone he went and bought another one
on credit
hey George was right George is 100
tonight this ends
tonight you have to look across the
table and say
um you've been committing Financial
infidelity
you're violating our vows you are
cheating on me
and I think we get really obsessive in
our culture about Fidelity being one
thing and one thing only in its intimacy
with somebody else and I think
Fidelity's my commitment to you I'm all
in is way bigger than that
he's cheating on you he's stealing from
you he's lying to you and at some point
you got to say hopefully it's tonight
you put a put a piece of paper down and
you say this ends right now how much
money have you borrowed in our family's
name
how much do we owe and where is it
because it man you made that one call to
Lowe's and you made that one other call
over here and you found out a whole
Litany of things you shouldn't have to
call Lowe's to figure out what your
husband has been up to no he should be
able to pull out the statement hand it
to you here's how here's how bad it is
but how dare he you take a turn at the
money and they keep keep borrowing more
money
that's wild
and I was gonna say I asked him the
other day like those kind of kinds of
questions are you cheating on me or what
other money has been borrowed and that
sort of thing and he did mention
another credit card not like thousands
or anything it was like 300 or something
but at this point at this point I don't
trust him I want to see his credit
report I don't either so I don't know
what to do tell him to bring his credit
report to the table both go to
annualcreditreport.com you can pull it
for free both of you have to pull that
we're gonna look at this thing with a
fine-tooth comb lay out a plan and go if
you're not on board this is not going to
work we have to have a different
conversation
no more lies
cannot continue this relationship on a
throne of Lies it will not work so I'm
wishing you the best Marielle but you
got you got some more cut out for you
I'm so sorry you're going through this
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
George Campbell joined by Dr John
deloney well folks your chance to win 3
000 bucks it ends today that's right all
month long we've been asking you one
question what would you do with an extra
three thousand dollars whether that
means paying off debt putting a little
extra toward your Investments paying off
the house early or planning something
fun for your family make sure you enter
the Ramsay cash giveaway today is the
last chance to enter to win the final
three thousand dollar grand prize and
yes real people win this thing and it's
some of the most fun our team has is
getting to contact them to let them know
and it could not be easier to enter all
you got to do is go to
ramsaysolutions.com giveaway it'll take
you less than 15 seconds to enter and
it's probably the easiest money you
could ever win even easier than crypto
John I've heard it's really easy there's
no such thing that's easier than crypto
crypto will send us all well here's the
best part there's no purchase necessary
you don't have to buy any crypto which
is so great and you do have to be 18 or
older to win sorry kids tell Mom and Dad
so hurry up enter the Ramsay cash
giveaway today before it ends
ramseysolutions.com giveaway let's go to
the phones Alyssa joins us in Fresno
Alyssa welcome to the show
hi thank you sure what's going on
[Music]
two and four and
Garde hold on whoa I'm confused hold up
two is it two or four how is it both
we're on we're on two okay wait we're on
four then we bought a car so uh Alyssa
what are you doing
I know
um so here's my question you're like I
know all right next kicking myself but
we're enjoying the car so we'll get
there
um here's my question we own a home here
in California and my husband recently
was given a job opportunity about two
hours away at the coast
um which would be fantastic for his
career for a stepping stone future job
advancement things like that obviously
the cost of living at the beach is much
much higher than where we are now
um but the quality of life we would have
there would be way better than what we
have now I would say we have some family
in the area over there and the climate
is much better
um Is it wise to keep our house as a
rental here and move over there knowing
that the potential is there for
long-term rental with like very little
chance of actually owning property
so you're saying we won't be able to
afford a house so we're just going to
rent in the new location keep ours as a
rental
I don't like making that big of a
decision based off the potential for
something yeah do you own your house
right now are you still renting it I
mean you still you still have a mortgage
on it
we still have a mortgage yeah yeah so
how much Equity do you have I would sell
it yeah
you have about 165
inequity what's it worth
450.
okay
so you got a big old mortgage on this
thing
yeah okay so what if we sold it and we
got out of debt and we had our emergency
fund and we began to save up for a down
payment in this new location and started
planting Roots there
or that's our other option yeah yeah I
wouldn't keep it and be a long distance
landlord because right now you guys are
already broke and now what if it needs a
new roof or the HVAC goes out you're two
hours away and you have to pay up 10 15
grand for these repairs
yeah I see it went from a blessing to oh
my gosh why did we do this we thought it
was a good idea yeah I would sell that
and cut your ties and if this job is
incredible then
um that's I mean it makes all the sense
in the world it sounds like and by the
way it sounds like you're going it just
sounds I mean you gave me all the
reasons why you should go so y'all are
going
I would go in with their eyes wide open
and George just said something really
important I don't want you to miss it
you don't go into it saying we can never
do you can
you might have to squash this beach
lifestyle for three or four years and
really save and really scratch and
really claw but you can you can 100 you
can he's getting a raise right
yes and I imagined you know the cost of
living is higher but you're also going
to have a higher income are you going to
work yeah
yes so I work here and I could continue
to work remotely what's your new
household income going to be
probably be
8 800 a month
that would be your take-home pay
yeah okay and then what would your rent
be
probably about 3 500.
that's a lot of rent
I know
so my goal would be let's get in a home
when it makes sense and that means a
15-year fixed rate mortgage where the
payments no more than a quarter of our
take-home pay and so that means you've
got to get that mortgage down below 3
000 for this to make sense
which means saving up more down payment
are we talking like a million dollars
for a condo over there what's the going
rate
yeah probably
800 for a condo or a million for a house
okay so this might mean we got to get
our income up ASAP and we're gonna live
on less we make we're gonna put away 10
20 30 grand a year towards this down
payment 50 Grand a year towards this
down payment and in a few years we're
going to be able to get a house there
and it may be a condo or town home
because you're living one of the most
expensive areas of the nation but you
don't you don't get a pass on math which
is unfortunate I wish because we get so
many people with who live in big cities
expensive cities and they go this plan
doesn't work I'm like it's especially
not going to work if you avoid it and do
what you want to do and your rent is
half of your income
so right that's the important thing you
can it's just gonna take sacrifice and
the question you'll have to ask yourself
is do you want to live the beach life
and go to the shows and go to all these
things and do rad stuff and get right by
depreciating assets with borrowed money
do you want to be those or like no we
want to buy a house and so we're willing
to sacrifice for five years we're going
to live kind of low-key and we're going
to do free things on the beach because
it's so stunning and beautiful because
we have one goal and that's we're gonna
buy a house man you could do that you
can do that I'm just gonna come at a
cost the same as it's going to come at a
cost if y'all choose to play and party
and have fun it's going to come to cost
of you're never going to own a home and
half of your income is going to be taken
up with rent banking somebody else Rich
so that's you got a choice either way I
know the choice that I think would be
wiser over the Long Haul for sure thanks
for the call let's get a quick one in
here from Robert in Syracuse Robert
what's going on Robert
thanks so much for taking my call hi
guys hey what up
uh so okay I'll try to make this quick
um
I'm a father and a father of four
children husband
um first the first five years of Our
Lives we live by ourselves in a little
tiny Hubble in Upstate New York I work
for the church I expected never to make
too much because the situation we were
in uh it was a
um it was a decision we made so that we
can serve the church and we expect there
to be very little when it when it came
to money five years into the marriage
our parents moved into the area and they
bought a house and they offered uh for
us to move in
um and enjoy the benefits of a
multi-generational household especially
as our kids were getting older and we
were homeschooling and it seemed like a
really good idea at the time for the
first few years it went really well
recently though there's been a lot more
tension and especially the two women in
the household about who's going to be uh
head mom and um bro move out my question
Robert move out this is your wife and
your mother-in-law and your mom move out
so her my mom my mom and my wife yeah
yeah move out
yeah I mean that's that was the question
it would mean saving up for a while
though because well no it doesn't it it
means you may have to reconsider
because you've created a life you've got
four kids
yeah y'all created a world that cost x
amount of dollars
yeah and you want to serve you want to
work at small rural underprivileged
underserved churches which is noble and
good but you've created a world where at
this time in your life that's not
possible
yeah because you got four kids
so it doesn't mean you're gonna put this
on for a long long time because you got
four kids growing up in tension so thick
they can't breathe
yeah and so it might mean you gotta take
another job that might mean you got to
leave Upstate New York where it's
expensive to live and find another
another place to live
it might mean we got bunk beds stacked
to the ceiling and it's a big old party
and we have that already hey they're
used to it you sit down with your wife
this weekend you all go out together
y'all make a plan but you got to get out
of there and y'all got to make some hard
decisions not about what you want to do
but what you got to do with the reality
that you have created for yourself
thanks for the call Robert this is the
Ramsey Show
[Music]
foreign
this is the Ramsey show our scripture of
the day comes from Luke 6 27-28 but to
you who are listening I say love your
enemies do good to those who hate you
bless those who curse you pray for those
who mistreat you
Benjamin Franklin said love your enemies
for they tell you your faults
hey before we go take a call I want to
George go back to that last caller
because I know we're going to get some
internet grief about it
I think we have in it's a cultural
honestly it's a yeah it's a cultural
problem
where we've been told follow your
passions we've been told
have kids we've been told you to buy a
house you've been told
um you should get a raise just for
showing up we've been told a bunch of
things that if you lay them all out and
do them all they don't make they don't
work it doesn't work there's not a
unified path forward
and so I've tried over the last decade
to figure out what what is that path
then and I keep coming back to the
starting line over and over and over
which is you have to choose reality the
reality that sits before you
and that reality might be I'm terrible
at basketball it's not in the cards for
me it's not going to happen
and I can work and work and work it's
not gonna happen it's okay it's all
right it could be I
so you put a book in front of me and I
just I just want to pull both of my
eyeballs out of my head right fine
you're probably not going to be a
Content writer and so if you have dreams
of being a writer and you hate reading
and you don't like practicing writing
you have to start with reality if you've
got four kids or six kids and you want
to be a person of service you've created
a world that can't you can't afford
right so you go back to the New
Testament Paul says if you have a wife
if you've got kids
Your Allegiance has to be to them it
can't be to this other thing right so I
think for everybody who's I want this
but I want this but I've got this a
starting place to be well and Building
Wealth over the long term is being
honest about where you are right now
that's why Dave says pull out one sheet
of paper and write down all your dead
smallest to largest that is choosing
reality right that's why a mental health
professional when you sit in and they
say how can I help you today right now
and you lay it out there the doctor says
where does it hurt right now you gotta
start with reality otherwise you just
end up all over the place man it's it's
just it's untethered feeling I want this
but I can't have that and then you end
up with four kids stacked to the ceiling
on bunk beds in your parents house and
your wife and your mother about to stab
each other to death right and Dad
listens to murder podcasts they'll never
find the body it's the whole thing's a
mess all because hey we have to be
honest about the world we've created for
ourselves and we wanted to do job X it's
not going to happen we've got to go I
gotta go because work in I.T I got to
start a yard business whatever it is
because this is my reality and that's
not a pessimistic or cynical no it's a
beaut it's a free it's Freedom it's
Freedom it's freedom and if you live in
New York City but you also really want
to be a homeowner it might mean you have
to leave New York City I am you know
what I'm not Brad Pitt
the chances of me being a lead romantic
interest in a movie Zero Zero zero so I
can
spend all that angst and all that energy
all that fighting ah or I can try to
become the best character actor of all
time first you know what I mean I can
own reality and be the best at that
thing you just sit on something
important you and I both talk to young
people who
I they they just moved to New York I'm
just gonna live there I'm gonna do this
I'm gonna and they find themselves
living in a three foot by one foot
coffin that's a closet with a full
kitchen and a bathroom and a bed in it
and they're paying eleven thousand
dollars a month for it
and they can't move and you just gotta
back up and go what life and they want a
yard and a dog too
what you got you gotta choose reality I
don't know if I could stamp that on the
if I could tattoo that on every person I
come in contact with I think we live a
healthier World well and the sooner that
anyone whether they're young or old the
sooner you realize that the less
resentment you'll have later on in life
when you look back and go oh my gosh I
wasted so much time and what if and if I
just had known if I just made that move
so the sooner you can look in that
mirror with full reality The Good the
Bad the Ugly the sooner you can make the
right path forward exactly that's a good
word all right let's go to the phones
Joshua Joins Us in Greensboro North
Carolina Joshua welcome to the show
hello Mr ruler and Mr Campbell it's a
pleasure to speak to both of you you too
what's going on
offering me a car or to buy from them I
just got my license
um like a week ago I'm 17. and they're
offering me it's a
2003 John Dodge Durango it's been very
well taken care of and everything
they're offering it to me for fifteen
hundred dollars and that's like I do I I
don't think you feed the young cars you
say it's a great deal but but I do have
um some problems with buying it it's for
financially it's a great buy but I was
just wondering and I do have like some
money history with my parents so just
like stuff that's happened and and I'm
wondering should I just put that all
aside all right and buy this car since
it's a really good deal like what I
should do what do you mean money history
are there strings attached if you buy
this car
yeah like I'm afraid that if I buy this
car it's gonna like come back to bite me
later tell me what that means right
um what has happened in the past what's
happened in the past that makes you
think that will happen in the future
uh I've had problems with my bank
account like I have my own bank account
and I've had my parents go in it before
without telling me and taking money out
of it and
they have replenished it they did put it
back and I I told them directly I do not
mind if they put take money out of my
bank account if they put it back I just
want to know so I know where my money is
hey Joshua yeah what happened to you is
not right
I'm sorry
Mom and Dad shouldn't steal money out of
their kids accounts
and like like I said it's not a big deal
hold on hold on it's a huge deal
you're talking to a current parent and
George is about to be parents we're not
going to take money from our kid we're
going to steal from our kids
it is a big deal and it hurts when it
happens it scares you didn't it
and it violated the trust that you have
with them so you're learning a valuable
lesson right now that I hope you never
lose because all of the world around you
is going to try to take this from you
and that is Joshua's trust in Joshua
that feeling in your gut
this deal is amazing
and I don't think it's right
so one of my rules of thumb for one of
my rules of life is George and I were
just talking about like I have a guy and
that's not a gendered thing it's like
I've got I've got a friend and she is a
she's a cancer researcher if I have a
question I I call her why she's
brilliant I got a friend who is a um
trauma counselor if I got a question to
call her got a buddy who's a banker I I
don't even think about it but at the
same time
I don't do any sort of business ever
with people I don't trust
period even if it's a good even if it's
the deal of a century because like you
said it will come back and bite you I
think you know the answer and I think it
breaks your heart that your parents have
put you in this position that you can't
even take a great deal because they're
not trustworthy is that right
yes sir well what will happen is and I
think you smell this coming down the
road as they say hold on no no we need
money we gave you a deal on that car
that car was worth five thousand dollars
so really you still owe us 3 500 or they
take it back when you're going to
college like uh hey we need that call we
need an hour car back our car broke down
that was really our car we gave you such
a deal it's not really yours right you
could you can tell these situations you
know it's gonna happen right Josh
and that that's what I'm afraid of and
that's the exact reason why you
shouldn't do this yeah I dude I hate
this for you the the one the one twist
might be
if you got something in writing
and I understand how incredibly
difficult that would be
but if you sat down with your mom or dad
and said it really scared me and it
broke my heart when you took money out
of my account and it made me lose trust
scared me
and I'm afraid I'm gonna buy this car
and you guys are gonna do something else
like that again in the future and I got
some wisdom from some guys who see
families hurt each other all the time
and I'd like you to put in writing that
that put move the title into my name
this is my car
and put in writing I'm selling this car
to my son fifteen hundred dollars and he
owns the title to it so they can't come
take it back from you you wanna have
that conversation then I'd entertain it
but that's a really tough conversation
for a 17 year old to have may just be
past to say the best to say thanks Mom
but no thanks
that was this hour of the Ramsey Show in
the books my thanks to John deloney my
co-host all the folks in the booth
keeping the show float and new America
thank you for listening until next time
spend wisely save intentionally and give
generously
[Music]
foreign
hey it's George camel if you like what
you heard in this episode and want to
know more about getting started on the
Ramsay baby steps go to
ramsesolutions.com and click on the get
started button we'll help you figure out
the best next step for you based on your
specific situation that's
ramseysolutions.com and click get
started foreign
[Music]